PRESIDENT WENT AFTER SO CALLED
MAGA REPUBLICANS FOR PUSHING
WHAT HE CALLED SEMIFASCISM.
>> TRUMP AND THE EXTREME MAGA
REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE THEIR
CHOICE TO GO BACKWARDS, FULL OF
ANGER, VIOLENCE, HATE, AND
DIVISION.
BUT WE'VE CHOSEN A DIFFERENT
PATH.
FORWARD.
THE FUTURE, UNITY, HOPE, AND
OPTIMISM.
I MEAN IT SINCERELY.
WE CHOOSE TO BUILD A BETTER
AMERICA.
>> LET'S BRING IN BAKARI
SELLERS, A CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR, AND FORMER
DEMOCRATIC STATE REP IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.
WE ALSO HAVE SCOTT JENNINGS, OUR
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR, AND A
FORMER SPECIALIST FOR GEORGE W.
BUSH, GENTLEMEN, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
I'LL START WITH YOU.
AS A DEMOCRAT, DO YOU LIKE THIS
STYLE OF PRESIDENT BIDEN, DO YOU
LIKE THIS RHETORIC THAT HE'S
USING?
>> I LOVE IT.
I MEAN, SEEING DARK BRANDON AS
THE TWITTERS SPHERE CALLS HIM,
FIGHTING, DEFINING, REPUBLICANS,
BEING A MESSENGER AND STANDING
NEXT TO THE FUTURE.
WES MOORE WAS JUST OFF SCREEN
THERE AS THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE
FOR GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE
OF MARYLAND, YOU LOOK AT HIS
OPPONENT WHO IS A COMPLETE AND
UTTER NUT, YOU TRULY HAVE THE
DICHOTOMY THAT IS PRESENT IN
AMERICA'S POLITICAL SCENE RIGHT
NOW, AND JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY
BEING ARTICULATE, BEING CLEAR,
DEFINING REPUBLICANS, STANDING
ON ACHIEVEMENTS, PUNCHING THEM
IN THE FACE, ALLOWING US TO
FOLLOW HIM IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
WANT, IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
FOR IN MOMENT, AND HE WAS IN
RARE FORM LAST NIGHT.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
SEMIFASCISM COMMENT BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T SAY IT AT THAT RALLY.
HE DID IT AT DONOR'S HOME
BEFORE.
IT'S A QUICK SENTENCE HERE.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS EITHER
THE BEGINNING OR THE DEATH NAIL
OF AN EXTREME MAGA PHILOSOPHY.
IT'S NOT JUST TRUMP, IT'S THE
ENTIRE PHILOSOPHY THAT UNDERPINS
THE I'M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING.
IT'S LIKE SEMIFASCISM.
SCOTT, YOUR REACTION TO THAT
DESCRIPTION OF THAT PART OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> YEAH, WELL, I MEAN, WHEN I
HEAR THAT, AND OF COURSE ALL WE
HAVE IS THE TEXT, WE DIDN'T HEAR
HOW HE SAID IT, BUT WHEN I READ
THOSE WORDS OR HEAR YOU READ
THEM, WHAT I HEAR HIM IS
MALIGNING ALL REPUBLICANS.
REMEMBER, 74 MILLION PEOPLE
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP IN THE
LAST ELECTION, AND WE KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
HAVING VERY THIN SKIN WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T DO WHAT HE WANTS
THEM TO DO OR IS POLITICAL
OPPOSITION TO HIM.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, HE WAS
SAYING IF YOU DIDN'T AGREE WITH
HIM TO FEDERALIZE OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM THAT YOU WERE BULL CONNOR
OR JEFFERSON DAVIS.
BAKARI PROBABLY REMEMBERS HE
TOLD AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS, IF
THEY DON'T VOTE FOR HIM, THEY'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO BE BLACK BEFORE.
WHEN HE GETS IN CAMPAIGN MODE,
HE GETS PRETTY NASTY, PARTISAN
AND SHOWS HOW THIN HIS SKIN IS.
I APPRECIATE DEMOCRATS LOVE
FIGHTING JOE AS WE GET INTO THE
MIDTERM ELECTION, YOU HAVE TO
ADMIT IT'S NOT CONGRUENT WITH
THE KIND OF PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN HE RAN IN WHICH HE
PROMISED TO UNIFY THE COUNTRY,
UP LIFT AMERICA, SAVE OR SOULS
OR WHATEVER IT WAS HE WAS
SAYING.
THIS IS IN DIRECT OPPOSITION TO
THAT.
>> HOW DO YOU CLASSIFY THEM, THE
ONES WHO SAY DON'T BELIEVE THE
TRUTH, WE LOVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNTIL THE LAWS APPLY TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
THE PARTY USED TO HAVE A
PLATFORM, AND NOW IS LITERALLY
IS WHATEVER THE LEADER WANTS TO
DO.
HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE THAT PART OF
YOUR PARTY?
>> WELL, LOOK, THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT I
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THEY
THINK, AND EVERYTHING THEY SAY,
AND THERE ARE I'M SURE PARTS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT BAKARI
SELLERS AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THEY
SAY EITHER.
THAT'S THE NATURE OF POLITICAL
PARTIES.
THEY TEND TO HAVE WINGS AND
FACTIONS AND NOT EVERYBODY IS
ALWAYS IN ALIGNMENT, BUT IN THIS
MIDTERM ELECTION, MOST
REPUBLICANS ARE ALIGNED ABOUT
ONE ISSUE, AND THAT IS THEY
DON'T LIKE RADICAL PROGRESSIVE
LIBERALISM, AND THAT'S HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE, AND WHEN
I HEAR JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND TRYING
TO DIVIDE IT UP INTO SECTIONS,
HE'S MISSING THE POINT.
THE POINT IS THE REPUBLICAN
PLATFORM IN THIS ELECTION IS WE
DON'T LIKE THE DIRECTION THAT
JOE BIDEN IS TAKING THE COUNTRY,
AND SO THEY DO WHAT THEY DO
EVERY ELECTION, TRYING TO DIVIDE
REPUBLICANS AGAINST THEMSELVES.
I'M NOT GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN
IT HERE TODAY BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS ELECTION IS ULTIMATELY
GOING TO BE ABOUT.
>> I HEAR YOU, SCOTT, BUT IN
OTHER WORDS YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A DISTINCT
MAJORITY OF WHAT BIDEN WOULD
CALL MAGA REPUBLICANS NOW IN
YOUR PARTY?
>> I MEAN, I THINK DONALD TRUMP
IS CLEARLY THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
REPUBLICAN IN THE PARTY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S OBJECTIVELY TRUE, AND I
THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS PROBABLY
THE MOST DISLIKED POLITICIAN IN
THE COUNTRY WHETHER YOU'RE A
MAGA REPUBLICAN OR A McCONNELL
REPUBLICAN OR ANY KIND OF
REPUBLICAN, AND SO, I MEAN, YOU
CAN SLICE IT AND DICE IT ANY WAY
YOU WANT, BUT THE ONLY THING
BIDEN IS TRYING TO DO IS TO GET
REPUBLICANS FIGHTING WITH EACH
OTHER SO THEY'RE NOT FOCUSED ON
THE JOB THAT HE'S DOING AS
PRESIDENT, WHICH MOST
REPUBLICANS WOULD SAY IS NOT
VERY GOOD.
>> OKAY.
BAKARI, HERE'S WHERE THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATINGS
ARE, THEY'RE UP.
>> I WANTED TO RESPOND, ALISYN,
I'M OVER HERE CHOMPING AT THE
BIT.
MY FRIEND SCOTT JENNINGS IS A
COMMUNICATIONS GURU AND EXPERT,
AND YOU HEAR HIM EVEN TODAY
TRIPPING OVER HIS TALKING POINTS
WHEN TALKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
THERE ARE MAGA REPUBLICANS,
SCOTT JENNINGS IS NOT EVEN A
MAGA REPUBLICAN.
SCOTT JENNINGS WASN'T AT THE
WHITE HOUSE OR CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6TH, HE DOESN'T SUPPORT
THERE, BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WERE THERE, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT IT.
THEY ARE NOMINEES RUNNING FOR
UNITED STATES SENATE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION, WHO ACTUALLY
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
WON THIS PRESIDENCY.
SO THAT'S WHO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THAT IS SEMIFASCISM, AND YOU CAN
SAY WHAT YOU WANT TO SAY, AND WE
HAVE TO CALL IT OUT AS TRUE, AND
YES, THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS AND
FACTIONS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
I DO NOT AGREE WITH.
DO YOU KNOW WHO ALL DEMOCRATS
AGREE WITH WHEN THEY HEAR HIM
SPEAK LIKE THAT LAST NIGHT.
THAT IS JOE BIDEN, WE ARE ALL
WITH JOE BIDEN AS HE ARTICULATED
LAST NIGHT, WHAT OUR VISION WAS
AND WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING AGAINST.
SCOTT JENNINGS, WE MIGHT NOT BE
FIGHTING AGAINST YOU ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
BUT WE ARE FIGHTING AGAINST
THESE MAGA REPUBLICANS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE ONES WHO TRY TO
DESTROY DEMOCRACY.
>>> LET'S NOW PUT UP THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING,
BAKARI, IT'S UP A BIT.
40%, WHAT WAS IT, 36 A BIT AGO.
56% DISAPPROVE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE FORTUNES
FOR DEMOCRATS HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
SHIFTED HEADING INTO THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS FOR THE MIDTERM
ELECTION.
>> IF YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED ME
THIS QUESTION IN JANUARY,
FEBRUARY, I WOULD SAY WE WERE
DEAD IN THE WATER, IN FACT, I
BELIEVE I SAID IT ON EVERY SHOW
I WAS ON.
THE FORTUNES HAVE CHANGED, AND
THE REASON WHY ARE A FEW THINGS,
ONE, THE REASON WHY IS NOT JUST
THE DOBS DECISION BUT THE
OVERREACH BY STATE LEGISLATURES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOU LOOKED AT KANSAS, WHAT OTHER
STATE LEGISLATURES ARE DOING,
YOU SEE PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
VOTING HOW THEY FEEL, THEY'RE
PUSHING BACK AND FIGHTING FOR
THEIR FREEDOMS.
THE OTHER THING IS THIS WHITE
HOUSE, AND YOU HAVE TO GIVE
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER A
LOT OF CREDIT, THEY HAVE DONE
SOMETHING THAT EVEN MITCH
McCONNELL WAS NOT ABLE TO DO
WHEN HE RAN THE SENATE.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PASS
LEGISLATION WITH VERY THIN, VERY
VERY THIN MAJORITIES, AND
THEY'VE MADE GOOD ON CAMPAIGN
PROMISES.
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS -- WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S FORGIVING STUDENT
LOANS OR WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPOINTING THE NUMBER OF BLACK
JUSTICES THEY HAVE, PARTICULARLY
BLACK WOMEN TO THE SUPRE